signal der einigkeit die g7 betonen zum
gipfel-abschluss demonstrativ den
zusammenhalt und versprechen mehr fürs
klima zu tun debatte um den mund nasen
schutz weil die korona zahlen weiter
deutlich sinken fordern immer mehr
politiker jetzt weniger masken pflicht
und das drama um christian eriksen sein
zustand ist stabil die anteilnahme
riesengroß nach dem herzstillstand auf
dem fußballplatz
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg herzlich willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesen
dreizehnter juni kristin otto ist auch
dabei für den sport wer gern guten abend
wir rücken wieder zusammen und wollen
vorbild sein das ist die botschaft zum
ende des g 7 gipfels die führenden
westlichen wirtschaftsmächte versprechen
ärmeren ländern hilfe sowohl beim corona
impfstoff als auch beim klimaschutz auf
ein konkretes datum für den
kohleausstieg konnten sie sich
allerdings nicht einigen
aus cornwall diana zimmermann auch den
letzten tag des gipfels begann der
gastgeber mit einem sehr kühlen bad bei
der anschließenden arbeitssitzung der
erweiterten g7 zum klimaschutz machten
die regierungschefs betroffene gesichter
schließlich einigten sie sich darauf 30
prozent all ihrer wasser und
landesflächen unter schutz zu stellen
ich glaube das bekenntnis zum
klimaschutz um 15 grad ziel zu dem
pariser abkommen von allen g 7 ländern
das ist schon ein starkes bekenntnis
sehr zufrieden zeigte sich die
bundeskanzlerin auch darüber dass bis
ende 2022 nun sogar 2,3 milliarden
impfdosen an ärmere nationen verteilt
werden sollen
es war angela merkels letzter g7 gipfel
zu ihren erinnerungen zählt seit gestern
ein barbecue am strand von carlsberg wie
unter freunden und die briten ließen
sich nicht nur für ihr grillgut
bewundern
wir reden hatte es in den tagen des
gipfels natürlich auch gegeben
die amerikaner forderten einen noch
härteren umgang mit china und mischten
sich in den drexhage streit zwischen
großbritannien und der eu ein
nicht nur die führer der g 7 staaten
auch ihre bürger haben schmerzlich
wahrgenommen dass wir in den letzten
jahren abwesend waren uns nicht
engagiert haben
amerika ist wieder da um die welt
anzuführen gemeinsam mit nationen die
unsere wichtigsten werte teilen
am frühen abend bekam joe biden noch
eine audienz bei der queen als
dreizehnter us-präsident ihres langen
lebens in israel könnte in diesen
minuten eine ära zu ende gehen benjamin
netanyahu muss befürchten nach zwölf
jahren das amt des premierministers zu
verlieren
neue regierungschef will natalie bennett
von der rechtsnationalen jamina partei
werden
seine rede in der knesset dem
israelischen parlament wurde mehrfach
unterbrochen ehemalige unterstützer
werfen ihm verrat vor weil er ein
bündnis mit den linken und einer
arabischen parteien geht ja michael
warum in tel aviv ein fragiles bündnis
aus acht ganz unterschiedlichen parteien
bilder netanjahu ablösen wird es heute
im parlament klappen
also die abstimmung hat noch nicht
begonnen aber es gab erst mal dieses
unwürdige schauspiel von ultra
religiösen und ultra nationalisten die
im wahrsten sinne des wortes versucht
haben den designierten
ministerpräsidenten bennett bei seiner
rede niederzuschreiben dass es nicht
gelungen
der hat sich nicht provozieren lassen
sondern im gegenteil in aller ruhe sein
regierungsprogramm vorgestellt er wird
nicht alles anders machen aber vieles
neue hat betont dass dies eine regierung
für alle israelis sein soll
besonders werden wohl die arabischen
israelis davon profitieren
wie gesagt die abstimmung hat noch nicht
begonnen aber ich gehe davon aus dass
diese neue mehrheit obwohl sie doch aus
so vielen unterschiedlichen partnern
besteht ganz entschlossen ihre mehrheit
durchbringen wird am ende zählt auch
eine relative mehrheit das würde dann
das
ära der das ende der ära netanya
bedeuten und den beginn der ära manager
peet auch wenn man noch nicht sagen kann
wie lange die wohl dauern wird
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
tel aviv nicht wie wochen war das zu den
crooner zahlen in deutschland die sinken
weiter aktuell liegt die bundesweite
sieben tage incidents bei 17,3 und nicht
nur politiker stellen die frage ob dann
überhaupt noch wunsch mund nasenschutz
masken getragen werden müssen
bundesjustizministerin lambrecht sagte
die länder sollen es klären
aus berlin david geppert noch immer gilt
an viel besuchten orten mitunter masken
pflicht doch mit sinkenden corona zahlen
sinkt auch die bereitschaft vieler den
mundschutz zu tragen und so fordert
heute die bundesjustizministerin
die verantwortlichen in den ländern
müssen laufend genau prüfen ob und wo
eine masken pflicht noch verhältnismäßig
ist wenn die inzidenz zahlen niedrig
sind und weiter sinken
das gelte insbesondere für die schulen
den schüler seien besonders betroffen
forderungen die masken pflicht generell
zu kippen kommen heute aus der fdp und
der afd
die masten pflicht muss weg sie ist
nicht mehr zu begründen sie ist der
sichtbarste ausdruck für den
ausnahmezustand der es jetzt zu beenden
wir müssen wieder gesicht zeigen und
zurück zu normalen verhältnissen
doch noch sei die pandemie längst nicht
überstanden man andere die komplette
aufhebung der maske pflicht wäre jetzt
ein fehler drinnen kann man sich nach
wie vor ohne masken infizieren und also
daher wären wir dann in einer situation
dass ich menschen noch wenige wochen vor
der impfung infiziert und deswegen
sollte man jetzt nicht unvorsichtig
werden
ich glaube dass auch bei niedrigen
instanzen die möglichkeit weiterhin da
ist dass wir vorsichtig bleiben
kürzlich hatten csu spitzen selbst auf
der einsamen zugspitze demonstrativ mit
maske posiert bei
beim fußballschauen im vollen biergarten
wird sie längst meist weggelassen
wo macht die maske noch sind diese
diskussion dürfte den heißen wahlkampf
sommer drehen in großer einigkeit haben
die grünen zum abschluss ihres
dreitägigen parteitags ihr wahlprogramm
verabschiedet sie wollen mit einem
klimaschutz sofortprogramm bis 2030 70
prozent weniger treibhausgase freisetzen
sie wollen die bahn ausbauen und auf
autobahnen tempo 130 einführen
außerdem soll der spitzensteuersatz auf
48 prozent steigen und der hartz iv satz
um mindestens 50 euro angehoben werden
patrizia wiedemeier am ende des
parteitages der bundesvorstand feiert
sich selbst das wahlprogramm mit wenigen
änderungen verabschiedet streit oder
heftige diskussionen fehlanzeige
jetzt könne der wahlkampf beginnen so
annalena baerbock da wird der wind auch
mal wieder von vorne von hinten von der
seite kommen aber dieser rückenwind von
diesem parteitag wird deutlich machen
in diesem sommer ist alles drin die
partei geschlossen
die grünen treten an mit einem öko
sozialen programm das bürgerliche wähler
nicht verschrecken soll es macht einigen
leuten große angst dass wir grüne uns
neu aufgestellt haben damit erfolgreich
sind
sie sehen dass wir grüne einen plan
haben wie sich klimaschutz und wohlstand
verbinden lassen
sein ehrgeiziges ambitioniertes programm
wir werden im wahlkampf uns häufig
anhören müssen wir wollen zu viel wir
wollen zu schnell
aber alles was sie beschlossen haben
lässt sich bei optimalen bedingungen in
der wirklichkeit umsetzen
die botschaft der grünen ist klar wir
wollen unbedingt im bund regieren ob
dieser parteitag hier den erhofften
aufschwung bringt für die grünen und vor
allen dingen für kanzlerkandidaten
baerbock das ist fraglich robert habeck
war hier sehr viel präsenter er hielt
die fäden in der hand erhielt die
bessere rede
annalena baerbock war sichtlich
angespannt und nervös und das obwohl die
partei ihren demonstrativ den rücken
gestärkt hat mit einem sehr guten
wahlergebnis aber auch alle
änderungswünsche beim wahlprogramm die
wurden abgelehnt
berufswünsche ebenso im heute journal
spricht claus kleber mit partei chefin
annalena baerbock und jetzt zu dir
christin und der frage wie geht es dem
ständischen der englischen spieler
ericsson ja also man sagt er lächelt
schon wieder das ist ein gutes zeichen
der mittelfeldspieler war während der
partie gegen finnland in kopenhagen
zusammengebrochen und musste nach einem
herzstillstand wiederbelebt werden
ein großer schock inzwischen sind alle
medizinischen tests absolviert und gut
verlaufen
momente der erleichterung bei dänischen
und finnischen fans als nach eineinhalb
stunden bangen die erlösende nachricht
kam ericssons zustand sei stabil und er
sei bei bewusstsein
auch am tag danach gibt es noch kein
abschließendes medizinisches dossier
aber der dänische team arzt bestätigt
einen herzstillstand
auch heute viel kritik an der uefa am
wieder anpfiff des spiels nachdem sich
beide teams für die fortsetzung der
partie entschieden hatten
es war falsch die spieler zwischen den
zwei szenarien entscheiden zu lassen ist
wenn solche schlimmen sachen wie bei
christian passieren müssen wir abwägen
was am wichtigsten ist ihm aus dem
brocken mitgefühl zum beispiel wie jogis
jungs mit ihrer grussbotschaft an
christian eriksen erfolgreicher einstieg
für die engländer vor heimischer kulisse
das 1 0 gegen vize weltmeister kroatien
war im zehnten anlauf der erste sieg in
einem wm auftaktspiel der kniefall von
englands nationalelf zum zeichen gegen
rassismus von fast allen fans beklatscht
statt wie zuletzt darauf zugreifen
dem sportlichen traum statt gegen
kroatien durch folgen steht der pfosten
im wege
sechste minute höhepunkt der neuauflage
des wm halbfinals schon 2018
dieser feine pass von philips und die
verwertung von rahim sterling 57 minute
das tor des tages gegen restlos
enttäuschende kroaten england feiert mit
1 0 den ersten auftaktsieg bei einer
europameisterschaft
einen tag nach den männern haben auch
die deutschen hockey frauen ihr em
finale in amsterdam verloren ebenfalls
gegen die niederlande
der entscheidende treffer für die
gastgeberinnen in
56 minute zum 2 0 endstand wurde nach
einem videobeweis regelkonform bestätigt
die titel für oranje
deutschland reißt aber auch als mit
favorit zu olympia und vielleicht klappt
ja dann in tokio der vielen dank
christian das wetter bleibt
hochsommerlich meist sonnig mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 23 und 30
grad nur ganz im norden gibt es
nachmittags einige wolken und auch die
kommenden tage bringen viel sonne plus
steigende temperatur hier freut sich
morgen wieder christian sie was auf sie
wir danken für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen einen guten start in die neue
woche